President Trump faces a new legal
challenge this morning from
congressional Democrats they plan to sue
the president over foreign governments
doing business with the Trump
Organization the suit focuses on a
clause in the Constitution intended to
prevent bribery 196 Democrats but no
Republicans are involved in this
challenge the attorneys general from the
District of Columbia and Maryland
recently filed a similar lawsuit major
Garrett's at the White House major good
morning good morning these lawsuits
allege that because President Trump has
not fully divested from his businesses
he receives gifts in the form of revenue
from foreign countries and generally
profits from the higher name recognition
his resorts and properties now have they
essentially seek more details on the
president's finances that means his tax
returns and if these lawsuits are deemed
legally viable the discovery process
they set in motion could bring those
lost could bring those tax returns
rather to light now all of this as
revelations about Special Counsel Robert
Muller's Russia investigation and his
own job security continued to swirl
[Music]
the president returned from a fundraiser
in Milwaukee last night to new
controversy after it was revealed mr.
Trump reviewed firing Muller chief of
staff Reince Priebus and white House
Counsel Don Magan reportedly alarmed by
the idea advised against it
the White House for the first time
confirmed president Trump interviewed
Muller for the vacant FBI directors post
the day before he was named special
counsel I have confidence in mr. moe
now that sessions has recused himself
from the Russia investigation only
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosen Stein
has the power to oust Muller if ordered
by the president something he was asked
about yesterday if President Trump
ordered you to fire the Special Counsel
what would you do if there were good
cause I would consider it if there were
not good cause it wouldn't matter to me
what anybody says the Deputy Attorney
General says he has seen no cause to
fire Muller thank you
during a meeting with Senate Republicans
the president kept his focus on health
care there mr. Trump flip-flopped on the
house-passed replacement to Obamacare
calling it mean the president had
described it as great and hailed its
passage in the Rose Garden but with the
GOP controlled Senate struggling with
the house bills reductions to Medicaid
and loss of coverage the president is
now looking for something softer to come
out with a bill that's going to be a
phenomenal bill for the people of our
country generous kind with hard no one
knows what that means because Senate
Republican health care deliberations
with this White House is blessing have
all been conducted behind closed doors
no public hearings are scheduled that's
a far more secretive process than the
ones that led to Obamacare in 2009 and
2010 that Galle Republicans then
described as secretive all right thank
you very much major